[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos
l'histoire de la vie des acteurs
économiques sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'entreprise diagou a été créée ici même
à montigny le bretonneux en 2015 son
activité l'ingénierie routière c'est à
dire le diagnostic de l'état des routes
en france en février 2021 elle a créé la
start-up road caire son activité
l'application qui permet d'analyser
l'état des routes à travers
l'intelligence artificielle nous allons
rencontrer les deux dirigeants de ces
entreprises
en attendant voici le programme de ce
16e numéro du sky
c'est l'événement autour des acteurs de
l'innovation sur le plateau de saclay
spring paris saclay se tiendra le 20 et
21 mai prochains les détails dans ce
magazine immersion au sein de
l'entreprise via goût et spécialisée
dans les études de l'état du réseau
routier
elle a donné naissance à la star se
corrode caire une application mobile
dédiée à cette activité
enfin découverte de l'atelier martin et
bergères à voisins le bretonneux créé
par l' artisan tapissier laurence baby
elle rénove des fauteuils ou encore des
rideaux on commence cette émission avec
le paris saclay spring un événement
dédié à l'innovation qui se tiendra le
20 et 21 mai prochains à l'école normale
supérieure de paris saclay cet événement
l'occasion de mettre à l'honneur 50
start up dans le sprint 50
parmi elles six sont installés à saint
quentin en yvelines
on découvre tout de suite la liste et le
programme de cet événement
[Musique]
à
voilà
[Musique]
on
et vous et de le voir rod caire fait
partie des startups sélectionnées dans
le sprix 50 avant de rejoindre son
créateur découverte d'abord de
l'entreprise à l'initiative de cette
start up il s'agit de diagou et suivez
moi on va rejoindre son fondateur
[Musique]
philip ryan est avec nous bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
développement de diagou et diagou et
c'est une société créée en 2015 à
montigny-le-bretonneux 15 collaborateurs
aujourd'hui un centre d'affaires d'un
peu plus d'un million d'euros
et puis votre activité c'est
l'ingénierie routière vous êtes un peu
le docteur le médecin des routes c'est
ça exactement nous occultons les routes
pour en faire pour en déterminer les
pathologies et pourrait également aider
les gestionnaires à l'entretien donc à
déterminer quelles sont les maladies des
routes
alors justement qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve
comme type de pathologie alors on peut
retrouver des pathologies on mesure ce
qu'on appelle le profil transversale par
exemple quand vous avez leur mirage
leurs mirage
c'est un aspect de confort mais
également de sécurité routière puisqu'il
peut y avoir des de rétention d'eau et
dans ce cas là on peut pas refaire un
aquaplaning
voilà un des exemples mais aussi des
nids-de-poule des fissures qui se sont à
peu près s'il ya bien sûr les nids de
poule les fissures les arrachements les
réparations toutes les toutes les
pathologies toutes les dégradations
qu'on peut voir à la surface lorsqu'on
circule en voiture alors qu'ils sont vos
clients nos clients ce et les maîtres
d'ouvragé publics et privés
ça va de la petite commune qui à 50 km à
gérer ou à la société concessionnaire
qui ont plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
à gérer ou des départements
vous êtes écrit en 2015 l'entreprise est
à peu près six ans comment elle évolue
elle est en forte croissance
nous avons de plus en plus de demandes
dans le domaine de l'auscultation pour
les collectivités locales et
territoriales
alors vous venez de vous présenter votre
activité une activité donc de diagnostic
de l'état des routes et vous utilisez
diagou et 1
donc c'est l'un des deux véhicules qu'on
voit derrière nous et oui c'est un des
véhicules que nous utilisons dans le
domaine de l'auscultation notamment pour
les réseaux départementaux et les
réseaux communaux alors on voit sur ces
images y circuler en même temps il capte
l'image comment ça fonctionne tel outil
on voit aussi sur le sur le camion alors
sur le camion vous pouvez voir il ya
différents outils il ya notamment aux
mesures qu'on appelle le profit de
transversales donc les déformations
transversale mais également le profit de
l'original donc le confort le confort au
niveau des de l'usager et mais également
la macro texture c'est une des
composantes de la de l'adhérence donc de
la sécurité routière
et puis l'outil innovant s'érode caire
c'est votre spin off
une entreprise a été créée au sein de
dia gouët et justement on va rejoindre
antonin mancelle pour parler d'europe
caire
[Musique]
rod caire est une jeune start-up
puisqu'elle a été créée le 1er février
2021 et nous sommes avec son co
fondateur entonna mancelle bonjour
bonjour alors road caire doit sa sa
naissance à diagou l entreprise dans
laquelle nous sommes depuis ce que or au
caire propose une solution de diagnostic
des routes sur une application c'est ça
exactement en fait routière est une spin
off de jag way et c'est la version
simplifiée du diagnostic routier c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de camions
avec tous les équipements on a juste
besoin d'un smartphone d'une application
est la nouveauté c'est que c'est
également directement la collectivité
qui peut réaliser le diagnostic ont régi
avec son smartphone et d'autres
applications quand ça fonctionne en fait
alors il suffit de télécharger
l'application dont il faut avoir un
smartphone mon télécharge l'application
on fixe le smartphone sur le pare brise
ensuite il suffit de rouler on parcourt
donc le gestionnaire parcours sont
linéaires il scanne son réseau nous on
récupère la donner hélas données
collectées et analysées sur le serveur
par l'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est là où tout l'inventaire se
fait des dégradations une poule les
fissures et toute la restitution se fait
ensuite sur sur une interface full web
donc le gestionnaire une fois de retour
au bureau se connecte avec son mail et a
accès à tout l'inventaire des
dégradations qui est réalisé aux notes
de bons mauvais moyens et aussi au plan
de travaux que l'on propose suite à ce
diagnostic
vous dites l'intelligence artificielle
c'est elle qui va analyser l'état des
routes c'est à dire concrètement il ya
une fissure
elle identifie sur la route c'est ça en
fait on a justement grâce à diego est
une énorme base d'image une base de
données qui sont déjà analysé donc on a
fait apprendre à la machine à
reconnaître ces dégradations et donc de
cette manière on peut le faire de façon
automatisée à grande échelle
donc ça à la fois plus rapide et aussi
plus objectif parce que l'intelligence
artificielle fera toujours les mêmes
choix
elle va pas on trouve le matin ou le
soir changer de critères cette solution
est destinée à un client particulier
enfin un groupe de clients en tout cas
les collectivités et notamment les
communes qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens pour payer investir dans une
étude assez globale sur leur réseau
routier c'est tout à fait ça les
communes ont des budgets restreints
d'entretien de la voirie et donc c'est
vrai que souvent la partie étude et mise
à la trappe
nous ce que l'on propose c'est d'avoir
une étude alors qu'il fera pas tout ce
que pourra faire dialoguer mais qui
permettra d'avoir un premier état
initial un premier diagnostic et des
pistes de solution et qui permettra
d'accompagner la collectivité dont
justement la gestion de sa compétence
voirie en lui donnant des données qui
sont fiables sur son et qui sont
actualisable sur son réseau routier
merci anthony man c'est avec grand
plaisir le cofondateur de the road caire
une aventure entrepreneuriale qu'on
suivra bien sûr ce notre antenne et nous
on va prendre maintenant la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux on va rencontrer
laurence badie est les dirigeantes de
marquise et bergères son métier
artisan pâtissier à regarder c'est dans
ma vie d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
je m'appelle laurent gbagbo j'ai 53 ans
et j'ai fondé marquise hébergeurs en
[Musique]
c'est une activité en deux parties une
activité qui concerne le métier de
tapissier décorateur donc fauteuil
réfection de fauteuils de siège de
canapés et aussi tout ce qui est des
corps de fenêtres voilages rideaux ou
stores bateau par exemple et l'autre
partie c'est une
une activité de décoration d'intérieur
avec du conseil autour de la vente de
peintures et de papier peint souvent et
on refait le fauteuil à partir de sa
carcasse à ce qu'on appelle la carcasse
et le fus donc on leurs sanglots on leur
met avec du ressort
là vous pouvez voir derrière moi il doit
y avoir un fauteuil avec du sel en crin
donc ça c'est une garniture dit
traditionnel pique et ensuite avec de
l'eau moururent notre projet phare c'est
d'avoir travaillé avec le château de
breteuil depuis 2016 où on a eu quand
même 80 mètres de tissus des
échafaudages pour poser les rideaux ce
qu'on était à 6 mètres sous plafond et
peu près 20 kg par pardo uniquement
[Musique]
l'aventuré entreprenariale pour moi
c'était la possibilité d'être
indépendante d'être autonome et de prime
abord c'était la possibilité de redonner
une deuxième vie à des objets qui
m'était confiée la possibilité de
recréer des sillages et de les rendre
aux clients en voyant voilà leurs yeux
qui pétillent et d'autre part de faire
aussi un petit peu de création avec par
exemple cette ce petit fauteuil qui a
été trouvés dans les poubelles et qu'on
va remettre en état et qui pourra même
être mis à la vente par la suite et
d'autre part le faire savoir c'est la
possibilité de passer sa compétence
un jeune qui est motivé
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce sky échos merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]